[Music]
in mom oh [ __ ] you I'm scared I didn't
mean it sorry sorry I'm offended for you
uh I don't pay attention submitted by
Christmas tree I can't wait I love
Christmas a mom had an affair with her
daughter's husband and then tried to
kill him
damn I was cool up until the point where
she try to kill the husband you're cool
that she slept with her daughter's
husband yeah because boys may not us I
mean right now it's really popular where
the mom kind of catches the boyfriend
and her daughter and then they and she
teaches her daughter like how to have
sex get out this is how you know they
join together and then they have like a
bonding experience
so how families stay together it's just
I don't like it
it's just I'm telling you it's popular
right now how do you know the statistics
you know how much of that [ __ ] pops up
on my feed I'll think so Gina did say
incest porn is really in right now how
do you find out these [ __ ] friends oh
I don't know oh yeah she has friends
that work in the industry I met yeah so
all the scripts they keep getting assist
all incest scripts I'm so sick of this
[ __ ] incest porn why can't we go back
to the old school and do some pirate
porn I don't know all right so this
woman's mother her name is Kathleen
she's 58 years old from Florida I had
always happened in Florida yeah so she
had an affair with her daughter's 33
year old husband she must be like hat so
she must be tantalizing hmm these are
pictures are pictures of pictures
there's pictures but or this guy just
has hello standards
all right so what happened here was that
Kanna the daughter got into an argument
with her husband Michael and during that
argument it came out that Michael
confessed to the affair and seemed like
yeah I wasn't sleeping your mom or
whatever [ __ ] you oh and your momma
which I've been [ __ ] so I don't know
which one came first his confession or
the daughters but apparently the
daughter was also cheating with his dad
oh [ __ ] no I don't know with her that's
nasty that's pretty crazy
yeah I got family yeah they got into
this big ol thing and then the mom found
out that Michael told Hannah the whole
thing and then Kathleen went over to
Michael's home which I'm wondering isn't
that her daughter's home but I don't
know they're saying his home and started
egging her his home and his car
she was egging the car like like
throwing eggs egging don't waste food
what you meant like egging on yeah what
are you gonna do about know some get off
me homes while she was doing that I
guess he came outside of the home and I
don't know maybe yelling I don't know
what was happening but this mom starts
driving in circles and bust a doughnut
in front of his home and trying to run
him over and then he just kept trying to
like dodge the Picard
so she sucked his dick and she's trying
to kill him yeah because he ruined her
mother-daughter relationship he ruined
one this is one of those problematic
[ __ ] that don't [ __ ] think that
they have anything to do with anything
it's like never my fault he [ __ ] me I
have [ __ ] him that's her argument this
is I was expecting more missing teeth
they looked like decent people and they
looked the same age Danny dude that's
crazy and then she has two kids with
this weight this is that which was a mom
is that the husband in the back she has
more crow's feet than she does
Oh smart tired just two kids Wow her
face is covered that's [ __ ] up yeah
Michael they're decent looking people
and that's like a [ __ ] standardized
[ __ ] it's like perfect parallel like
Dracula and [ __ ] Wow
here's the mom you see her it's not that
glamorous yeah and then here's the mom
and daughter on the wedding day damn she
got big-ass [ __ ] arms look at that
[ __ ] why is it that lately I've been
seeing so many older ladies with tiny
little shoulders and big-ass triceps
maybe it's angle it's not triceps as fat
that's just it's harder to get rid of
that like to tone your arms up when
you're [ __ ] older my grandma got
big-ass arms before start getting very
skinny again it looks like the neck of a
turkey so here's the home where she was
doing donuts and egging that looks like
a nice lawn to do donuts on I haven't
seen a brick house in a long time yeah I
wonder if they should have [ __ ] is
she use the van like a soccer mom van to
do donuts on or is she like a cool mom
and she's got like a Mustang or
something no wait it's the older mom
right yeah it's the older mom the one
with the hair like at this one you know
what though the whole time I was
thinking what I [ __ ] any of my exes
mom's now I can't picture is just I just
don't know you don't want to [ __ ] no old
66 Asian lady with a visor on and all
that unless they're hot my old roommates
mom was hot and then he always got all
kinds of jokes from his friends all the
time I think it's even more disgusting
to want to have sex with a mom that
looks like an old job at a hut she
doesn't like Java dot no not her I'm
just saying like when a mom looks more
disgust okay true was on the mom [ __ ]
list you could be towards the top and I
think that's where I am and then there's
other mom [ __ ] that are down there Oh
cuz you're [ __ ] your wife no I'm just
saying like because he didn't give me
that crap I would have [ __ ] my
friend's mom but then she was hotter so
I paid towards I get it yeah so it's not
that disgusting
it's disgusting when your mom looks like
the lunch lady you're still gonna do it
look on Julia's face no I'm just
picturing the stereotypical like Asian
mom right like it's rare that you find
the word milf like now let's do like a
young mom but like our age the moms that
are like you know anyone that we're
dating at our age they're I mean I just
picture like you know a little bit on
the chunky side with curls still in
their hair and then in a yeah and they
got the visor with a glove that goes
down here they smell like [ __ ] tiger
balm yeah I'm lost balls sounds like my
mom she just has baby powder she's not
even ashamed he just comes with [ __ ]
all powder from here to here yeah they
kind of let go so they got a little
mustache growing oh my god I'm on those
is there any like legal issues or
anything is just drama and that's it at
nepo said of Maury as soon as the cops
arrested her she was admitting like I
wanted to kill him so attempted murder
yes she got charged on the charge of
aggravated assault with a deadly weapon
because what I don't understand is
there's a mug shot of the dude that was
from a previous he's already recovered
not troublemakers before they're saying
that the police in May went to that same
home earlier this year when the husband
and wife they got into an argument and
neighbors called pops when they heard
Hannah screaming and then a point to the
cops are saying that Hannah was having a
family dinner with Michael and their two
children who are two in six years old
and that's when the husband became
agitated in conversation when she was
telling him about an achievement at work
and then she told the cops that he
flipped out he got mad when she was
celebrating like something she did well
at work what'd she work at the strip
club I don't know hope not honey I I did
10 lap dances tonight over five how he
told us I could tell you don't tell me
butts too cold
but aren't you proud
and then they're like fighting hmm yeah
so that's when he got arrested because
they were both smelling alcohol and then
to this family's all kinds of [ __ ] up
very dysfunctional it seems like he gave
her a stolen hi oh [ __ ] punched her
damn dude this is this is like really
weird man
and then the babies they had the 6-0 in
the two year old I like crying his [ __ ]
and then like they're all drunk even
like weight to her than the six-year-old
the kids know the parents all drunk
eating hamburger helper and [ __ ] would
they're just Jonna some beers
yeah and that was the altercation I got
a mix up in my head that was the
altercation where she told him that she
cheated on him and then this recent one
is where it came out that he told her
that he was sleeping with her mother oh
he got it that good but they don't
mention how long your affair was going
on between the husband and the moms oh I
don't know since marriage this is why we
can I don't believe in democracy because
like most people don't understand that
there's a lot of people that exist like
this and they have the power to vote
that's true so I don't know man all I'm
saying is people can't be trusted with
their decisions was it that the most
interesting you've ever heard and your
whole entire life
I don't even know what you guys just
talked about but anyways please
subscribe for more random videos more
funny content and more hahaha poopoo in
your pants stuff go ahead subscribe and
for more videos right there
[Music]